[elevator dings]
Lucifer.
Maze. Just in time.
Detective, would you like to
go out with me this evening?
[Chloe] After I saw your face, I felt lost.
I just wanna get back to work.
The detective is clearly in denial.
Help me.
Take it slowly.
How is Lucifer?
I'm sure he is just fine.
[music playing]
Yeah.
Hey, Luc.
Eve?
Long time no see.
[music continues playing]
Who are you?
I'm Eve.
As in Adam and Eve?
Lucifer's bringing his girlfriend
on cases now, huh?
She's actually really sweet.
I don't think that you understand
the dangers of having Eve here.
When the Devil finds his first love,
evil shall be released.
Eve is amazing.
She appreciates that I'm the Devil.
I'm guessing this won't end well.
[both laugh]
Could you accept who I truly am?
[screams]
I don't know.
You don't have to change.
You're already perfect.
This is not who you are.
I'm the Devil.
[music continues playing]
This is going to be so much fun.
[music ends]